doctors and teaching hospitals here in
the United States received about six and
a half billion bucks from drug and
medical device makers in 2014 government
data released yesterday showed the money
length between companies and health care
providers prescribing their products
basically way you mean you think they're
greasing the wheels with that money I
didn't say I'm thinking that China all
I'm doing is saying data came out we're
gonna have the best person at Bloomberg
break this down through Armstrong he's a
health care editor for a Bloomberg News
drew hey guys how's it going what's this
all about okay so back part of Obamacare
we had this loss one of these sunshine
laws it says cough up exactly what you
pay to doctors and teaching hospitals
your drug company you invent all sorts
of products but you're also a really big
sales organization so this is the first
year that we've ever had a full year's
worth of data on this we got to see
everything for last year we've got about
I think close to 10 million dollar 10
million different lines of Records on
this that we've been going through I've
got a data team in San Francisco pouring
through this our folks here what we
thought you had about two and a half
billion dollars worth of payments that
went for things like paying for dinners
paying speaking fees for people those
little squeezy toys you see in the
doctor's office pens the Pfizer clock
that sits in your doctor mainly this is
money to send doctors to Hawaii so they
will continue to describe your brand of
viagra but actually believe it or not
you don't pay to send the Doctor Who I
you pay him to give a speech while he's
in Hawaii flies itself a NATO patata my
main question might I mean obviously we
know they do this yes but glaxo I was
gonna stop doing this why would you stop
doing this well they did this a plan
called patients first the idea was what
you know we're not gonna pay doctors for
this stuff anymore better relationships
was to be based on science were actually
hasn't been working out great for them
but they did spend 15 million dollars on
it last year is really banks who say
clients first gotta grease the wheels
your Armstrong he's our health and
science editor Bloomberg News